if you're holding yourself back from
doing something that you really want to
do because other people are telling you
that it's not a good idea I'm gonna
share with you a clip from Dame - on how
to not care about what other people
think if I make a regular business that
doesn't touch pop culture doesn't make
history then to some people that could
be considered going backwards
that's not pressure for me because I
could care less what people think and I
don't think there's anything about my
career where you would think I did it
for someone else I'm just constantly
trying to impress to myself like I've
accomplished you know relatively
speaking a lot of things and because of
that I've been able to do exactly what
inspires me so this is a great reminder
that the bigger your idea is the more
you want to have a positive impact the
more what you're trying to do is
different and outside the box from the
normal standard life the more hate
you're gonna get the more negativity
you're gonna get and the more
discouragement you're gonna get from
people saying don't do it the key thing
for you to figure out is if you want to
live your own life on your terms or if
you want to live other people's version
of your life you see if you went into
the safe thing the thing that most
people do where you graduate goes from
school and go get a job and work there
forever
nobody's gonna hate on that right that's
the safe smart thing to do that
everybody does the only real problem is
you might be miserable going down that
path and you might regret for the rest
of your life that when you had that
child when you had that chance to do the
thing that you really want to do the
project that you really wanted to launch
you didn't do it and you always will
wonder what if and you're gonna blame
the people around you you're gonna say
well I didn't do it because my parents
didn't want me to do it or I didn't do
it because my friends didn't think it
was a good idea or I didn't do it
because I put out a market research and
people the feedback that came back
wasn't positive but at the end of the
day the only person you can really blame
is yourself you have to stop living the
life that other people want you to live
and start living the life that you want
to live yourself believe thank you guys
so much for watching I love to know how
you have overcome other people's
opinions or that's something that you're
still struggling with leaving the
comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion and I
look forward to talking with you thanks
again for watching have a great day and
I'll see you soon